[Musique]
notre ca ce soir Claire Bolduc
Christiane Bergevin bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous et rebonsoir Christiane
oui on est heureuse heureux de vous
accueillir en studio toutes les deux
heureux aussi d'avoir quelqu'un pour
nous parler de cet enjeu de clé millier
quelqu'un du tennis à main on entendait
un peu plus tôt la hausse du nombre de
clims de la superficie aussi des clés
miniers en habitivité médicament qui
inquiète des élus des organismes aussi
qui demandent au gouvernement de mieux
encadrer le développement minier comment
est-ce que vous recevez ces inquiétudes
là comment vous percevez ça ce sont des
inquiétudes qui sont palpables
particulièrement dans le milieu plus
habités le territoire de l'abitivité
médicament guide du Nord du Québec était
un territoire géologiquement très riche
en minerais toutes sortes en minerais
qui actuellement ont une très grande
valeur sur le terrain toutefois la
possibilité de créer des mines là où on
trouve le minerai
devient une contrainte au développement
des communautés et à la protection de
l'environnement avec lesquels on devra
apprendre à composer moi quand j'allume
mon ordinateur quand je démarre ma
voiture électrique je veux que ça
fonctionne donc ça prend des minerais et
je pense que c'est pas mal tout le monde
qui va être dans cet esprit là mais je
suis aussi la personne qui était dans le
film de Richard Desjardins true story
pour dire il y a un modèle de
développement dans le secteur minier
qu'on doit absolument revoir on doit
prendre en considération beaucoup plus
le développement des communautés des
territoires dans leur ensemble et voir
de façon beaucoup plus sérieuse comment
on oriente les activités minières plutôt
que comment on impose les activités
minières sur les territoires
il y a la protection des escaires entre
autres qui est ressorti de la peur des
élus municipaux est-ce qu'on devrait
exclure complètement les escaires de
toute exploitation possible je pense que
c'est déjà ce qu'on fait les
municipalités notamment dans la dans
quelques merci de l'Abitibi elles ont
déterminé c'est souvent les sources
d'eau potable du monde municipal c'est
une ressource qui est essentielle et
très peu renouvelable alors sachant
c'est important qu'elle ait fait les
municipalités et les MRC qui déterminent
des territoires inaptes aux activités
minières elles doivent avoir aussi les
moyens de faire respecter c'est ça c'est
conséquences là tout va passer par le
schéma d'aménagement si on arrive à bien
définir le schéma d'aménagement avec les
interdictions les territoires inaptent
aux activités minières si on arrive à
bien intégrer donner des vrais pouvoirs
au MRC au monde municipal et de donner
des signaux claires aussi en matière de
développement minier on aura les outils
qu'il faut pour bien travailler le
secteur Christian nous avait suivi aussi
cet enjeu là on veut développer les
ressources entre autres pour la filiale
batterie filière batterie comment est-ce
que vous avez reçu ces inquiétudes
aujourd'hui
minier là c'est un problème de richesse
pour le Québec parce qu'on a comme le
dit claire sous-sol qui est extrêmement
riche
en même temps le foisonnement des clins
puis mâchoire un petit peu
pour aller au Québec il y a des clins
dans des municipalités qui ont aucun
précédent aucune tradition minière on
peut penser au sud-ouest du Québec il y
a une il y a 15000 Flins maintenant
alors assez d'accord que il y a des
préoccupations d'aménagement qu'on doit
avoir un modèle qui est basé sur un
aménagement un plan clair des ondes
désignés parce que quand on investit de
l'argent sur un investisseurs dans une
société d'exploration mais vu que
finalement ça puisse se poursuivre
harmonieusement pour amener un
développement réussi même si on a pas
beaucoup des clims qui mènent
une mine sur 1000 Klein c'est ça c'est
que oui ils achètent des clés mais en
même temps il y a peu de développer de
ces clean qui se transforment
développement est-ce que c'est justifié
de s'inquiéter lorsque vous êtes encore
que des clés pour pouvoir maintenir le
clim pour pouvoir maintenir sa validité
on doit faire des travaux de mise en
valeur du plein minier du droit minier
qui est présent sur le l'espace qu'on ne
réservé et ça ça fait des dégâts malgré
tout ça fait on a vu dans le communiqué
de presse par exemple des groupes
environnementaux on a vu l'espèce de de
barbouillage sur le territoire ça fait
ça laisse des traces ça laisse des
marques qui sont importantes je pense
que on doit avoir une meilleure
connaissance du sous-sol et de là où les
gisements sont les plus riches c'était
le travail en reconnaissait le travail
des
des géologues à l'époque en leur
laissant l'opportunité de développer la
mine parce qu'ils avaient fait l'effort
de trouver l'eau où c'était très riche
maintenant je pense qu'il faut mieux
connaître notre sous-sol et diriger le
développement plutôt que de se le faire
imposer maintenant j'aimerais vous
entendre aussi sur bon la controverse
autour de la Banque de développement du
Canada des dépenses d'Isabelle Hudon la
nouvelle PDG qui sont contestés entre
autres mandat la firme Mackenzie de
presque 5 millions de dollars une grande
revue stratégique est-ce que c'est
justifié selon vous Christiane d'avoir
ce genre d'exercice un regard extérieur
d'abord il faut dire que la
transformation de la BDC c'était entamé
avant l'arrivée d'Isabelle Hudon c'était
une des recommandations du rapport du
Conseil sur la stratégie industrielle du
Canada copilotée par Monique Leroux et
Sylvie Vachon parce que les firmes ont
besoin du capital et l'industrie est
passée une industrie beaucoup numérique
digitale alors qu'avant on est prêt basé
sur des actifs alors pour faire cette
transformation là est-ce que ça prenait
est-ce que ça prend un regard externe
bien oui il faut baliser le monde il
faut savoir qu'en France on est modèle
extraordinaires ou qu'ailleurs on a fait
ça mais c'est normalement un complément
aux équipes internes puis ça doit être
fait dans le cadre d'un processus qui
est bien balisé
la richesse d'une nouvelle dirigeante
dans une organisation c'est qu'elle est
capable de s'adapter aux forces vives de
cette organisation et qu'elle est
capable de composer avec ses forces
vives là certaines dépenses à ce
moment-ci apparaissent peut-être
justifier on verra à l'usage et si le
rapport de 5 millions n'est pas du tout
utilisé cette dépense là était farfelue
et inutile alors c'est vraiment la
capacité de la nouvelle PDG à mettre en
oeuvre les recommandations qui auront
été faites sa capacité identifier les
actions porteuses et les porteurs de
dossiers dans son équipe à partir de
l'équipe qui avait déjà là parce que
c'était beaucoup il y a eu beaucoup
changement à la tête de l'organisation
YouTube beaucoup de progrès aussi moi
j'ai tout conseil d'administration il y
a longtemps j'ai quitté en 2009 écoutez
en 2022 l'année qui s'est terminée le 31
mars 2022 puis Isabelle était juste là
depuis 8 mois puis c'est pas
nécessairement la planète stratégique
c'est pas nécessairement elle mais
écoutez la BDC a généré un profil 2.5
milliards de dollars ça c'est c'est
trois fois plus qu'en 2018 avant la
pandémie on servait plus d'entreprises
plus de femmes plus d'auto tonnes alors
il y a des belles choses qui se passent
à la BDC
en même temps et donc si on sert plus
d'entrepreneurs d'entrepreneurs on va
gagner il faut savoir mieux travailler
et je pense l'entreprise l'institution
n'a pas 80 ans d'existence sans avoir
fait des bons coups avant l'arrivée de
Madame huton l'enjeu c'est vraiment de
composer et de faire des partenariats
solides avec toutes les instances de
développement économique qui relèvent
notamment des provinces je pense à nos
CLD je pense Investissement Québec je
pense qu'il faut vraiment faire des
partenariats solides collaboration
plutôt que de chercher à se
compétitionner sur ce marché-là il y
aura un examen législatif prochainement
est-ce qu'il y aurait fallu attendre
d'avoir le résultat de cet examen là
avant de brasser autant les cartes ben
écoutez pour avoir été au Conseil de la
banque l'examiner législatif c'est
statutaires c'est par là d'ailleurs il
était retardé à cause de la pandémie
alors si on attendait toujours la revue
législatives il se passerait pas grand
chose penser que même en 2009 en
souvenez la crise l'abbay des savait
pris des actions très très proactives
pour supporter l'économie alors je
dirais non on n'avait pas attendre en
même temps il va falloir démontrer que
la transformation que le nombre
d'entrepreneurs supportaient le capital
déployé les partenariats comme le dit
clair sont au rendez-vous mais c'est un
exercice qui est normalement bien
maîtrisé par l'équipe de la BDC si je
peux ajouter on doit reconnaître que
Madame Hudon c'est quelqu'un qui
propulse les organisations auxquelles
elle est associée
visiblement la visibilité l'aime alors
ça sert bien aussi la renommée de la
banque développement du Canada merci
beaucoup à vous deux d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci bonne soirée